>> All right, we're here today with Matt Mastracci
from DotSpots. And can you please introduce
yourself, your company and give a little overview
of your application and your innovations when
you were creating it?
>> MASTRACCI: Sure, so, my name is Matt Mastracci.
I'm the CTO of DotSpots. We founded DotSpots
a couple years ago as a way for people basically
to annotate the news. Give people a way to
attach relevant material to articles that
they might find on major new sites and major
blogs. The ideas is that we allow somebody
to attach something and then we use our engine
to distribute what they attach on one story
to semantically relevant areas on other new
stories that would be appropriate for whatever
they attach whether it will be media or their
own comments, etcetera.
>> So you chose to use that GWT to your grade
this up. Can you tell us a little bit how
you came to that techno decision?
>> MASTRACCI: Originally, before I worked
on DotSpots, I was working on some prototypes
of various applications and I came across
some information regarding GWT app. I decided
to give it a shot with one of my previous
projects. And that previous project, actually,
it didn't take me very long to develop. I
basically managed to go from a prototype to
implementation of that previous product very
quickly. So, when we started DotSpots, I decided
that I'd give GWT another try. We started
from the beginning from a fresh code base.
The--when we originally started DotSpots,
we wanted the experience for the user to be
very, very seamless. So, when the user visits
our website and they click around between
the various sections, we didn't want to have
to wait for page loads all the time. We wanted
to be able to click around very quickly and
get the information they want as quickly as
possible without having too worry about page
load time, etcetera. Additionally, at DotSpots
we actually provide the users a Firefox extension.
And, because we use GWT, we can use the same
code on our website that we do on our Firefox
extension and all we need to do is just a
simple recompile.
>> Can you tell us a little bit about the
scalability of your code?
>> MASTRACCI: Our code is scaled very well
from the beginning. Right now, we have at
least 40,000 or 50,000 thousand lines of client
source. And we found that our development
ability hasn't really changed that much. We--we're
using eclipse to develop our GWT Code. And
we still use the same remanufacturing tools,
the same--same code navigation tools that
we did when our source code was tens of thousands
and even less than 10,000 lines of codes.
So, we found that as our code scales, we don't
find that we'd run into the traditional problems
that a normal Web 2.0 company might where
you end up with such large amount of JavaScript
that when you try to make a change there's
just so much code that you have to spend so
much time changing that it's just becomes
an unmatchable match. So, we did--we tend
to do a lot of refactoring stone that. Being
able to do that with such a large and mature
code base has definitely have been a big advantage
for us.
>> What new features would you like to see
and are you most excited about?
>> MASTRACCI: Some of the 2.0 features that
we've seen in GWT that we're really excited
about, the outer process hosted mode is going
to be very important for us. We, right now
because we have a non-traditional GWT app
with Firefox extension we tend to have to
have to wait for about three to four minutes
while our compile finishes and the code is
linked and before we can restart a Firefox
browser to see our code in action. But now
that we have access to other process hosted
mode, we should be able to simplify that by
allowing our developers to start up the browser
with the other process hosted mode plug-in
and immediately see their changes reflected
instead of having to go through the cycle
again and again. As well the story of your
compile code that we've seen coming up seems
really interesting for us. Basically, we spend
a lot of time trying to figure out exactly
how we can make our Firefox extension as small
as possible. And we've been doing a lot of
that by hand, but now that we have--we should
have access to a more detailed description
of how our code is compiled. We can then shrink
the sites of our extension with significantly
less effort.
>> So, it sounds like you're pretty excited
about GWT. What would you say--still needs
to be improved?
>> MASTRACCI: Some of the issues we've been
having with GWT, again because we run as a
Firefox extension when a user doesn't update
their extension but we update our server code.
We tend to run into incompatible remote service
exceptions. So, we have some workarounds for
that, and we tend to--we have to force the
user to update their extension more often,
but in cases where the client and server code
may not necessarily be 100% in synch. We can
certainly--there could be some changes made
to some of the RPC code to make it easier
for us to deploy these things at different
times and have an up and down level compatibility
story. As well some of the work that we've
been doing in the extension requires us to
add in our own multiple document support for
widgets currently the quick code of course
assumes that you have a single document. We--it's
actually a testament to the architecture of
GWT, it didn't take us that much time, what
we've done is we've actually added our own
versions of the widgets which are just subclasses.
We support creation in a set, in another document
and that basically allowed us to use more
than one document on our GWT app.
>> So, to wrap this up how could you compare
your experience with GWT to your experience
of using other AJAX Tools?
>> MASTRACCI: I've used a number of AJAX Toolkits
over the years and GWT is actually a different
piece. When you work with the other AJAX Toolkits
you have to think separately about your server
code which is generating stat to get the HTML
and your client code which is augmenting it.
With GWT what you do is you build, you build
the product. You don't really have to think
about these arbitrary split between server
rendering and client rendering. You're just
always building; you're building one unified
product. And, because we can do, because we
just build a single product, we never, we
just kind of; we just go ahead and build it.
We don't have to worry about whether code,
something is going to be rendered on the server,
or something is going to be rendered on the
client. We don't have to worry about keeping
stuff in synch between the two because both
the client and the server are sharing the
same code and we basically just run our compile
process and it just works. So, it saves us
a lot of effort.
>> All right Matt. Thank you very much.
>> MASTRACCI: Great. Thanks a lot.